All right.
I want it to do,
they talk about 1968,
which I can even remember.
So I wasn't in France in 1968.
Um,
first of all,
1968 has to be put in the context of,
uh,
of a mobilization across western Europe.
And indeed in some places in the United States that had more to do with,
um,
uh,
then simply a reform in universities.
But he had a lot to do with,
with the world as people like me saw in 1968,
uh,
it was a time when the Americans were,
were,
uh,
at war in Vietnam.
And the student protests had a begin begin to,
um,
I began to expand,
uh,
the first teaching against the war in Vietnam,
which was in the University of Michigan in Haven Hall,
uh,
and about 1966 or maybe 65 or 66.
Um,
and,
and the movement spread a spread of the United States.
And,
and of course,
uh,
you've read about a 1970 a Yale when people,
exams did never happen.
And it was a time of the Bobby Seale trial.
Uh,
and so it,
that sort of generation,
this our baby boom generation,
whether it was in Rome or in Athens or in the Berlin or,
or,
uh,
Russell or,
or in a,
um,
you in Munich a well,
let's throw in Munich or,
or in Madison,
Wisconsin or in,
uh,
Berkeley,
California,
where the free speech movement had started a couple years before that.
It was all sort of linked together as people thought about what had,
what the downsides of,
of,
of the new prosperity that had come in France and other countries.
Uh,
and the expansion of the university system,
uh,
to,
to include more people.
Um,
and so,
uh,
this sort of waves of,
of,
of protest,
you know,
were linked.
And in the case of France,
if this is what we're talking about,
uh,
there were really two aspects of it.
There were the strikes a more about that in a minute.
And then there were the,
uh,
were,
were the,
the,
the student demonstrations,
uh,
the riots,
the aggressive,
a reaction by a,
the so called forces of water,
which is what they liked to call themselves.
Um,
and,
uh,
leading eventually to the resignation of,
of,
um,
uh,
of Charles de Gaulle.
So,
um,
it was at a time,
I'd rather like 1936 when everything seemed possible,
and it was full of a time of,
of great optimism.
And there all sorts of books published of,
uh,
of the graffiti of 1968 a as students,
most of whom smoked in those days.
One and two,
the Odi all theater and unfortunately burned,
uh,
with their cigarettes.
Uh,
uh,
the beautiful chairs of the audio on theater.
And when speeches went on and on and the solve button,
uh,
the war of words was,
was written on the walls,
uh,
of,
of the subways as I guess I'm in a Garfunkel one sang,
but,
uh,
of,
of the metal in Paris and on the walls of,
of the,
the [inaudible] a long live communication down with telecommunication,
you know,
reflected the,
uh,
the great uncertainty that technology and push button or remote controls.
And all of this was not enough in life.
Uh,
the more I make love,
the more I make the revolution.
Uh,
the more I make the revolution,
the more I make love every,
every view of things,
which is not strange.
His faults,
Amnesty and acts or which sovereigns forgive the injustices they have committed.
That's not a bad one.
A mankind will not live free until the last capitalist has been hanged in the
end.
Trails of the last bureaucrat,
not a very nice one.
That nor very original because that came from,
uh,
from,
the French revolution,
the radical phase of the French revolution,
that we will all be safe only even the last priest has been hung in the end
trails are strangled in the end trails of the last noble.
And so there was,
there was,
you know,
as they quarreled and they debated and they,
uh,
you know,
they battled a,
everybody didn't agree on everything and it was like the Paris commune.
Uh,
uh,
and there were a lot of childish aspects to it.
It was a,
it was a youthful resonance,
uh,
people my age,
so they're,
most of them are older than me,
uh,
that,
you know,
in those days,
professors you are old was one.
Uh,
and when I can remember,
and I believed it,
uh,
at the time,
never trust anybody over 30.
Uh,
I,
you know,
30 seems awfully young to me now.
Um,
it was in the wake of,
of the consumer revolution.
It was in the wake of the 30 glorious years of the French economy expanding.
And the same thing happened.
They west German economic miracle as well.
It was,
um,
a reaction to the kind of technocratic society,
uh,
that seemed unfulfilling,
that seemed to have turned capitalism in the state,
that dynamic duo loose on ordinary people.
And here it is,
tell it was tied to the war in Vietnam and,
and,
uh,
you know,
verbally rhetorically violent reaction against,
uh,
against American,
American way of sort of splitting up the world with,
with the,
with the Soviet Union.
And it has to be seen them in all of that.
And in it generated resistance.
I mean,
at the end,
uh,
you know,
we'll come into this in a while,
but there was a huge,
a huge march down the Sean's for these a and the of the,
of the,
the,
the prosperous people.
And you could see them from the 16th or on the small,
and there were ladies in their fur coats and they're flashing rings and they
were there to give their,
expressed their solidarity,
uh,
with the general,
to whom all of this seems something just strange from another planet that he
couldn't comprehend.
I didn't want to deal with,
uh,
just wished it was all going to go away.
Um,
in,
in terms of,
I mean,
also you have to put it,
you know,
it is linked to America's,
you have to remember an end.
You weren't even born then.
One of you was in this room and the iPad besides me,
uh,
you know,
Martin Luther King had just been murdered in Memphis,
Tennessee and,
and,
uh,
you know,
th th that was,
uh,
that was an enormous,
enormous event,
uh,
for,
you know,
for people of my generation.
And,
and it seemed that if you,
the harder you worked for social justice and,
you know,
people believed in,
in social justice and we believed in associations and organizations and the,
and then when people went out and up down in Mississippi,
you know,
to work in the civil rights,
uh,
March,
then they got murdered.
And,
and,
uh,
I remember going with a couple of friends of mine from Jesuit high school and we
join,
went out to north Portland and joined the Naacp.
And,
and you know,
we're,
we were 16 years old.
We could do.
We just learned how to drive and,
and,
and if you believe in social justice and,
and we weren't,
you know,
big Milton.
So certainly during the war we,
you know,
we,
we were,
we all were,
are many of us were,
but,
but then every time he thinks to be,
you know,
you took a big step forward,
then it just seemed like we were confronted with,
with,
uh,
the,
the Lyndon Johnson's and the,
and the,
and the Richard Nixon's of the world,
and with the [inaudible] and with the murder of Martha Martin Luther King.
And,
and so the,
these things did reflect a globalization,
uh,
it just,
as the Algerian war,
one of the arguments that I made,
which is Matt Connolly's argument is,
is that the Algerian war afflicted the globalization of,
you know,
technology in newspapers and,
and,
uh,
the,
the rebels getting the newspapers on their side about French torture.
Well,
the globalization of,
of,
of News,
uh,
you know,
with the God live from Vietnam and all of this business method issue.
So the,
the,
the murder of Martin Luther King and,
and the Americans plunging more and more money and more and more bodies into,
uh,
into wars,
in other places had ramifications from [inaudible],
which I'll talk about in a minute,
which is the university to the West,
one of them,
to the west of Paris.
And the,
and the swab been,
uh,
which is,
you know,
had been there for centuries and centuries and centuries since the medieval
period in the Latin quarter.
So,
you know,
the problems seemed,
did generate simplistic answers that if you thought hard and you would on an
work that you could abolish the excesses of capitalism,
you could abolish the excesses of the state and that there would be a more
reasonable world,
wouldn't it?
That the Lyndon Johnson's,
uh,
am I remember March 31st,
1968 announced he would not run for office.
And the Richard Nixon's that,
that,
you know,
people power,
that was a phrase that was used in France and the United States and Berkeley at
Columbia,
you know,
in Anarbor all sorts of places.
But specifically in France,
it had to do with,
um,
a crisis of education,
a crisis in education,
uh,
that education in a society that was still class based and to an extent is still
class based.
I had remained the privilege of the upper classes even as the numbers of people.
Uh,
uh,
in the university system in France had increased dramatically as all,
all across Europe had this had happened.
Um,
in 1938,
there were 79,000 university students in France in 1958,
59,
there were 192,000 in the same buildings.
In 1968,
1967,
68,
there were 478,000.
Uh,
that is a huge number.
And,
and,
uh,
in 1968 just since 1967,
the number had increased by 50,000 more in one year.
Now this is the baby boom.
I mean,
if you go back 18,
20 years before that,
you have the know of the family again.
I mean,
at the end of World War II.
So you've got all these,
these,
you know,
little babies who had grown up,
uh,
you know,
like me and you know,
we're in,
we're in universities,
but the university structure,
uh,
could not possibly welcome all of these,
all of these folks.
Um,
you know,
I have these really good friends in Leon.
It actually does not live in Paris and are they,
I met a Greek professor long time ago and she was teaching a,
in one of these,
a huge great university's in Athens where she had 1000 students in her class,
1000 and no tas,
you better come up with a question that you can grade 1000 answers to,
uh,
you know,
name three people,
uh,
name three,
19th century Greeks.
Uh,
you better come up with,
I mean,
it was an impossible situation for students and,
and,
and for a,
and for faculty.
And as now as in the issues now,
uh,
there wasn't light at the end of the tunnel because compounding the fact that
there weren't jobs unless you were in one of the grounds they caught,
that is the big fancy schools.
Unless you were in now one of these people in the administration school who was
going to just slide into some party post in a godless government,
uh,
and what was there at the end.
And you also had this,
this extraordinary ambiguity,
uh,
you know,
in thinking about there's their ambivalence because if you were basically
against the sort of technological super powered society of,
of,
of fast cars,
uh,
and,
the Americanization of,
of a European culture,
if you believe strongly against that,
you know,
what kind of job is there going to be at the end of the tunnel for you?
You can't be a professional militant,
you know,
your entire life.
What are you going to do?
And the people,
by the way,
who were,
who invested their careers or lost their careers in this mobilization,
uh,
we're toast because they refuse to sit for their exams.
Uh,
and they committed professional suicide right on stage cause they did it.
And it all starts with a lot of it.
When Daniel,
Danielle,
the cone bendy,
who was a militant when he was expelled from the University of,
of [inaudible],
uh,
because of,
of,
of his militancy.
So there was a lack of jobs,
particularly for those people studying the life of the mind,
uh,
studying,
art,
literature,
history,
uh,
and the structure had changed very little since Napoleon home bragged that when
he created,
you know,
the academy,
that he knew what everybody was studying at any,
any given time,
it had not changed.
And to some extent,
it still hasn't changed.
Now,
a more about that,
maybe in a minute.
The structures of the universities were extremely rigid in 1964.
Um,
2% of this university students were sons or daughters of workers and peasants.
2% in 1964.
This is what's called a class society.
And it had not changed very much by 1968.
Um,
and people blame the state for the rigidity.
I have a friend in effect,
the Gaullist with whom I waited in line to get into noto dom for the,
uh,
the Charles de Gaulle affair,
who I was supposed to take a,
he's a lawyer and he was taking an advanced degree and he,
uh,
he lived in the suburbs and he stayed in a prosperous suburb,
fairly prosperous,
but he stayed in Paris one night because the metro is closed and buses closed,
you know,
as if you didn't make the 1232,
then,
you know,
you had a long walk.
And I walked back to that suburban hitchhiked back and all of that,
some funny stories about that,
but not at the time.
Uh,
and he got,
he got back on a,
on Saturday to find,
uh,
a Matisse,
which was a way of communicating these little things that shot around and then
were delivered to your in tubes and they're delivered your house saying that he
was supposed to show up for the examiner to arrive on Friday when he was at work
and was supposed to take his exam on Saturday.
And of course he got it on Saturday at about noon when he got home after as long
night in Paris.
And that was the end of that,
you know,
then you just simply say,
well,
you know,
I guess I'll take it next time around if I happen to be here.
It was a rigid system,
uh,
that was unforgiving and,
and seem to seem to be perpetuating the kind of elite Ism and the kind of unfair
in a sociopolitical world,
uh,
against which,
people,
uh,
people struggled.
And a 1967 and the worst economic year of the sixties says,
I just said,
you know,
the Gauls response was typically said,
well,
we need to have more participation.
Kiss Cassava,
Dia,
what does this mean to have more participation?
You know,
what do you mean by that?
Well,
he meant nothing by that.
Uh,
he,
uh,
um,
you know,
in October,
1966,
his workers were,
we're getting increasingly Milton.
He said,
you know,
that the changes that we must bring to the working class condition as the active
association of work and the Active Association of the economy,
uh,
which we are all want to,
we want to accomplish all of us.
What does this mean?
It means nothing.
And so phrases like that census like that are reassuring for,
you know,
for the upper classes in Paris who were Leo and the sixth are on these more of
the arm or wherever,
who don't want to be Bruce Good Aa.
They don't want to be bothered by,
uh,
they,
they don't want to be bothered by the militancy of,
of,
uh,
students and of workers.
They want the Metros to run.
They want the buses to run a,
they don't want the students building barricades and all of this stuff.
So it's reassuring to them,
but it didn't mean anything.
Uh,
and what the goal was so completely out of it.
He said,
it's just to be Coop Bay.
They fall,
say,
you know,
I'm,
I'm a drift from the French.
I'm cut off from the French,
you know,
uh,
because he,
he,
uh,
he had no understanding it for,
for that the,
that,
the nationalism of French should be enough that the mystical body of himself
should certainly be enough.
But of course it wasn't.
And the demonstrations that many of them organized by the National Union of
Students,
um,
which had be done,
uh,
you know,
which was militant.
I had began in the 1950s,
or maybe the forties.
I don't,
I don't remember,
uh,
is Milton's,
he had declined after the Algerian war,
but then I,
it,
uh,
um,
you had this,
you have,
uh,
the student leaders,
I mean,
whose names you don't remember,
but,
uh,
they were young,
often young sociologists or one was in physics,
allows us with the names,
don't matter what they did to them.
And they did the people in my generation,
but they don't necessarily do you,
um,
they,
uh,
you know,
they were in sociology or an or it mostly in the,
in literature and history and,
and they all committed together,
uh,
professional,
suicide.
And so it begins with demonstrations and knocked out.
Now the French university system,
uh,
began with,
you know,
it began with a saw been,
um,
and the Latin quarter is so-called as you know,
because that's what people spoke in the Middle Ages.
Students conversed in Latin,
Latin was a living language.
Um,
and the first medical school,
Second Medical School in Europe,
his moped,
Yay.
The first was Polonia.
Uh,
and there was already a very strong university in Leon.
and uh,
there,
there are the act,
there was axe and there were other universities,
but the,
the big expansion of even the para system,
uh,
and of,
of provincial universities has come in response in part to a,
these big events,
uh,
in this heady time,
but they haven't necessarily brought,
uh,
brought many changes is as we'll see,
um,
uh,
see later.
And so I know that there's also a lack of a campus.
I mean,
if he was going,
I've taught in Leon and Leon do,
and I teach in a wall sometimes,
um,
and theirs,
with the exception of [inaudible],
which has a fairly nice campus,
um,
maybe we won't put the a little bit,
uh,
most of these places,
you know,
students don't,
most of them don't,
don't live in dormitories.
Uh,
and so they're just places where they go.
They're essentially all commuter colleges.
If you,
if you go to [inaudible] University of was,
you know,
one,
two or three,
there are also named in such a,
uh,
not terribly poetic way.
University of Paris is one,
two,
three,
four,
five,
six,
seven,
eight,
nine,
So you say,
where,
where are you a student when let's just be a bout,
he reads once just to be a body.
Got To us.
Good luck if you're a pal.
He got tossed a,
that's a really tough news.
And Oh my God,
uh,
it's just unbelievable.
These are buildings that were built already,
falling apart and are just out there and there's solace and,
and,
uh,
it's,
you know,
you're privileged.
Uh,
you've worked very hard to be privileged and Michigan,
we were privileged,
but you can't,
there's no sense of solidarity.
There's nothing to do.
There's no s sports really.
Basically there's equivalent of club sports.
There's just,
they would just sit around and smoke cigarettes and,
and,
uh,
there's just not much to do.
There's no,
there's no sense of esprit de Corps.
There's no sense of being in a former student of that place.
It's just you,
it's part of your existence for three years,
uh,
unless you're one of the grounds they call or the fancy folks and all that.
And,
um,
so even trying to get people to mobilize against the structure is in very easy,
but,
but the conditions,
they started out with these demonstrations against these,
uh,
against these conditions.
This is also tied,
and this is the point I,
I for,
for a stupidly forgot to mention earlier that,
you know,
the women's movement,
uh,
the,
although not terribly,
um,
uh,
dominant in France,
I mean,
it's still essentially a limited,
uh,
and this is probably an exaggeration,
but,
but to,
to the middle class feminists,
uh,
influenced by Simone de Beauvoir,
the women's movement also meant that,
that lots of women who were put four for their claims.
And again,
as I said,
that the vast majority of the students are,
are bourgeois students.
I mean,
they're upperclass students.
And so,
but,
but that,
that still was part of it.
And the way society is structured in United States,
then we're,
we're,
uh,
you know,
sexism was,
was even more endemic than,
than,
than it is that it is now,
uh,
that this,
this for,
for,
for Milliken,
females said this was part of the problem too.
I mean,
there's,
there was so much,
uh,
that seem to be having to be changed,
that it was very,
very frustrating.
And so,
uh,
there are occupations,
people in United States occupied administrative buildings.
Uh,
and fortunately they did often destroyed books.
it happened to Columbia and places like that.
Uh,
but there was lots of student occupations,
you know,
Yale,
there were two,
I mean,
I wasn't around a bit,
but there were two in the national guard,
if you can imagine the,
the national guard tanks coming up.
John Blum has told me about that.
My form,
my colleague,
former colleague,
now long retired,
but he,
uh,
you know,
Branford College was Luca Ledger,
who's Ya?
Uh,
and the,
um,
the,
you know,
I guess it had a red flag up or something and tanks were coming down.
If you could imagine tanks coming down or up York street,
between,
uh,
between JDE and Pearson there,
between Davenport and,
and Branford and,
and,
you know,
they were setting up little welcome centers and possible places to treat people
that are injured by the national guard who wanted nothing above of militant
privileged students,
you know,
in the night.
And May 4th,
1970,
done them down at Ken State with great pleasure.
Uh,
you know,
the,
these were different times,
but anyway,
so in France,
they started occupying up,
uh,
buildings.
And on May,
uh,
this Arbonne has closed down,
on,
on May set,
on May 2nd,
I,
and on May 3rd,
the police,
uh,
the police move in and now the police,
the crs,
we're hated.
We're hated the crs,
crs.
Uh,
many of them were southerners and rumors.
And I can remember these rumors that they were,
you know,
kept in their,
uh,
kept in their barracks and not fed enough.
And,
and,
uh,
given special sections on why,
you know,
why Milton workers and Milton students,
a representative,
the end of civilization as they had known it and,
you know,
they had their big,
you can still see this now cause they have,
they've made them feel they have free reign.
I Will Sarcozi uh,
you know,
there are big shields and their big helmets and what you call in French,
penny a salad,
these,
uh,
big trucks that,
that have grills on them,
you know,
and,
and like if you're shaking lettuce and,
you know,
they would suddenly come Taryn along the place and it wasn't just circulate,
like move along,
move along,
and they just beat the hell out of you.
And there's still more,
still not sure how many people died in all of this,
how many people were battered by these folks.
But you can tell,
I mean,
I grew up just hating these people,
just hating them.
You know,
you'd walk along a,
you know,
in the 70s even,
they'd be down in their trucks and blue are central man,
you know,
or,
uh,
your,
there'd be clustered around the Otis of the v.
Let me,
there's still a very contentious agent.
You just grew up,
you know,
if you're my generation,
I guess my politics,
uh,
you just,
you just just hated these people and nobody hated them ahead had reasoned more
to hate them.
And this may be unfair,
but,
but it's not an unfair,
uh,
than minorities,
because those are the ones that,
that,
that these white,
uh,
many of them,
of course it can,
but it's not just Corsicans,
but,
uh,
white people from the south who were moved into northern posts and,
and,
uh,
they,
they want,
didn't want to see North Africans or west Africans and folks like that around.
But anyway,
they move in.
Um,
they vacuum with this,
our bond and,
uh,
things get spin out of control.
And the May 10th to May 11th or the is the night of the barricades and the
barricades go up in streets that had not had to Oakmont is boulevards plowed
through them.
It was harder.
They,
where they do make some attempts than they do.
I guess if I remember right across the,
that that was the only year I wasn't there.
I said,
odd,
isn't it?
But,
uh,
as I first started going to France when I was a kid,
1967 and I'd been there at least four months every year since then,
and I wasn't there in 1968.
Uh,
but there were barricades built,
uh,
between Woolworth's,
Sandra,
who,
Sanjay Rock in the boulevard,
San Michelle,
you know,
in that sort of now touristy overrun with Mcdonald's quarter.
Uh,
there are tourist corridor and all around the room is still a price and all
around the ODL.
And,
uh,
the,
the barricades were built,
unfortunately,
many of them with trees that were,
that were ripped down on the,
on the,
on the boulevard side,
San Michelle,
they did a lot of damage there.
And they ripped up cobblestones.
Were streets,
still had cobblestones.
And they,
you know,
do shovel where these little,
uh,
a little,
very unsafe,
flimsy cars that you could,
I mean,
I wear this friend of mine picked up the front of a Douche,
a vote to move,
you know,
to park.
You can just pick,
literally,
you know,
this guy that you can pick it up and kind of move the front along.
And these things were easily transformed into barricades and,
and,
uh,
this was the night of the barricades and there was a lot of violence.
I mean,
these were real barricades.
And,
um,
and this was,
a want rather one sided violence,
but still a,
so there are 367 wounded,
several killed.
We still don't know how many,
uh,
and about 460 arrests.
Um,
before that,
even on May 6th,
during the fighting,
they were 1,422 arrests,
uh,
a et Cetera,
et cetera.
And the middleclass would,
was,
you know,
was shocked by the,
by the brutality of the fighting.
But they were more shocked by the fact that,
that you had workers and,
and,
and students,
uh,
who had not yet really coalesced,
that were,
uh,
defying the state.
And one of the obvious,
uh,
say,
s s s say,
uh,
say ais,
s s you know,
that as the SS,
as in the,
you know,
Hitler's a organization and,
and,
uh,
this is what a w w was,
chanted and,
uh,
um,
it was,
uh,
you know,
all the way up to the jar,
Dah,
Luke,
some more from which they could get materials also for,
uh,
these barricades.
Um,
how,
how did the government react?
The,
the,
the prime minister was,
so Georgia pump,
you do,
um,
you know,
a pure kind of gall us to who,
uh,
whose only resistance in World War II.
Incidentally,
this is a bit mean to say,
but he wants,
refused to sit next to a gestapo officer at a I in the opera,
in a Lowe's at the opera,
but plumpy do a,
had been in Afghanistan and he came back,
uh,
on,
May 11th and,
and orders the university reopening without the police.
Um,
and then he went off to Romania as planned,
and then he came back and found,
uh,
that,
um,
that that strikes had,
uh,
that,
that strikes had a,
uh,
had spread.
Now the strikes themselves,
uh,
you know,
we're,
uh,
both to separate but,
but related movement and the strikes came in the large and the reno plants in,
in,
uh,
[inaudible],
the same kinds of occupations that had happened in 19,
uh,
36,
in a way rather festival op,
uh,
festive occupations,
as Lenin Lennon.
One said with considerable reason about,
uh,
the commune,
he'd called it a festival of the oppressed and,
and,
and there was a,
you know,
a good humor in these occupations.
Again,
the same kind of guerrilla theater and,
and all of this great attention not to destroy the machinery that the workers,
when this all would settled,
uh,
would,
w w would come back.
Um,
but,
um,
uh,
on May 14th,
um,
uh,
and May 14th,
they're an aircraft plant near north was occupied.
And then the sit downs PR a strike spread as in 1936,
I May 16th workers occupy the gigantic Reno belong cool.
Uh,
uh,
who an old plant,
there.
And then it spread to two other ideas.
It was the largest,
I mean,
to other areas.
It was the largest mobilization of workers in French history.
Um,
without any question.
Even more than 19,
uh,
36 and rather like 1936,
it left the communist party confused and uncertain because once again,
it seemed to be that the tail was wagging the dog.
You know,
workers are striking on their own and they had slogans that weren't really big
communist slogans.
One was auteurs yes,
y'all that is workers self management.
The workers would run their own factories.
Now in the Soviet Union,
uh,
after the Russian revolution,
the Bolshevik and the communist party had crushed like grapes workers who
attempted to run their own factories and who wanted to have strikes and,
and,
and working the power of the proletariat,
uh,
in,
in the Soviet Union of,
of to an extent of Lenin.
But above all the stolen became the dictatorship of the communist party.
Uh,
work herself.
Management,
uh,
had,
was simply didn't exist.
It was run by the party,
uh,
in,
in theory it existed and the Communist Party was supposed to represent the
Russian and the Soviet working class.
But in fact,
you know,
the Communist Party had his existence of its own.
I,
and so suddenly they're confused cause here's our workers saying we want to run
the,
you know,
we,
we want to squat and strike now and said,
well wait and wait.
It was the same thing as I think there are six,
everything is not possible.
Everything is not possible.
Uh,
but for workers occupying their plants,
it seem to be,
this seem to be the moment that a w to do it.
And there's a strong link between big strike movements and political opportunity
as in 1936.
So it's a very,
very good comparison to make.
Taunt sees as six 30,
six and a 60 and 68.
And the workers want to participation in industrial decision making.
They want to control over the pace of work.
Again,
they were against Taylorism that they're being measured,
their performance that's being measured by the number of units of whatever car
handles,
whatever they're making a that they do,
they want to have the right,
which they eventually wanted to have a union office in the factory and to
collect,
to collect fees from workers for the Union and,
and make collect,
get,
collect.
So,
you know,
uh,
the pass the hat and union,
on behalf of the Union and on behalf of workers in the Union at,
uh,
during,
um,
uh,
at work.
And so the political goals can't really be separated from the workers movement
was all part of this,
this huge,
uh,
mobilization and workers and,
and,
and students had,
had really had a lot more in common and they're,
they,
uh,
then they didn't the United States,
cause I mean,
people of my generation can remember,
uh,
you know,
students at University of Michigan going down to the Ford plants in Ypsilanti,
uh,
at and other places and up in Flint.
And,
and,
uh,
the,
the workers there,
they didn't want it to hear anything about,
about these privileged white students opposing the war in Vietnam.
They wanted to,
you know,
have a boat and go out and Lake Michigan,
Lake Huron,
uh,
and they,
they were,
you know,
the wolf,
the United States government is fighting a war in Vietnam.
And I must be United States government knows what it's doing.
A,
and they didn't want any part of it.
And so it was a total of talk about a failure to,
to,
uh,
to comprehend a,
it,
it just,
it did,
it didn't work.
And to an extent,
this isn't probably not a fair comparison,
but it would rather be be like,
uh,
you know,
Milson and Columbia and Yale and Harvard and Michigan and w Madison,
uh,
activists,
some white and some black going down to Alabama and Mississippi.
Uh,
and,
and trying to talk to people down there because it just,
it didn't work.
But in France,
uh,
because the,
the state structure seem to be,
uh,
in a very centralized structure,
not a federalized structure,
so you could find time common cause,
uh,
because you're the factory worker who was occupying a factory,
his enemies,
the crs,
uh,
and the students,
who are afraid they're going to get gunned down by it,
by the crs.
Uh,
they,
they have things that they're,
um,
they had in common and they were both fighting against the brutality that
brutalization as they would have put it of human relations is that capitalism
seem to be,
uh,
simply perpetuating this favored society in which the rich do very,
very well.
Thank you very much.
And the grounds,
they call our full of only people who are well connected.
Basically.
That was always the case,
the big fancy schools and the brutalization of human relations on the shop floor
with,
uh,
you know,
the bosses are dictating the rhythm of work.
So it seemed to be,
you know,
there seems to be this sort of moment where,
where some,
you know,
progress,
um,
uh,
could be made.
Um,
and then the sense that you're powerless within the system and the French
educational system you were in to an extent still are powerless.
And in the factory you were powerless.
And eight,
you're probably arguably more powerless,
not because the role of the unions has,
has declined,
uh,
in the United States,
I mean,
in France as a United States.
And in the end,
um,
uh,
you know,
the government had to pass laws,
uh,
giving,
legal,
uh,
status,
within each factory to the union that they could,
could collect funds.
Uh,
as I said,
I guess I already said that,
and,
uh,
could,
could had an office,
uh,
there,
but the education reforms,
uh,
basically a scratch the surface,
the,
uh,
beginning,
creating new,
uh,
a new universities.
Uh,
uh,
all,
all over the places.
And now there's only a couple of day pop them all in France that don't have at
least branches of universities.
The most recently created real our shell,
which is going very nicely and to [inaudible] in a Haas.
Uh,
but even these,
the,
even the,
these lead to problems because of,
for example,
when they create a university in La Rochelle,
uh,
then you're particularly,
you,
you are hurting an old established university Poitier,
you know,
which becomes a sort of instant rival La Rochelle does for students from the
area around La Rochelle and the Patek La,
uh,
that is up,
you know,
in a Haas,
uh,
you know,
what does that hurt?
Well,
that that is resisted by Leela,
obviously in leader three universities in the leads,
a big student center.
Um,
so,
uh,
even in places that are major university towns,
and to lose a is a good example.
I mean,
they create more universities or they expand the University of,
of Toulouse.
I mean more branches and stuff like that.
And,
and,
uh,
but does this solve the problem?
It really doesn't because,
um,
because French universities remain woefully underfunded.
And that's why this issue of this law that's been proposed in the past,
I guess the law,
the pet krass law,
Pec,
r,
e,
s,
which is to make these budgets autonomous of universities represents the kind of
an Americanization of the French,
a system where,
uh,
the,
the favored will be do even better.
You know,
Bahia [inaudible] which are very different,
very Paris.
One is,
uh,
you know,
associated more left wing university,
more progressive.
Uh,
Perry of Paki for four category is,
is a more right wing,
uh,
university,
Leon.
Do you know a place like Leon do as opposed to if you have a one in the old
three,
you know,
is going to do very,
very well to lose as can do very well under the system,
won't Pva will do very well.
Maybe they'll be able to raise money from,
from,
uh,
alumni and they're not even,
it doesn't even exist in an alumni association for these places.
They don't even exist.
Uh,
you know,
it's just totally different.
I mean,
even a PR,
a public university in United States like w Michigan,
even in hard times.
And we just are so very well because the University of Michigan is so identified
with,
I'm a little proud of it,
but identified with the state of Michigan or Wisconsin or Berkeley.
I mean Berkeley might have hard times,
but,
but you know,
the California system has so part of the state of California,
you're not,
it doesn't do much good to argue to the business.
Whole University is associated with the Department of the dew,
which is the approximal business song because,
you know,
unless the state gives the money there can give me any money coming in.
And so,
uh,
you have more and more people and uh,
has anybody here been to a French University?
Yeah.
Where were you?
Barclay.
You were in Paris,
weren't you
when you went to the lectures and all that and stuff like that were they're
enormous numbers of people.
Um,
so,
so I feel like
we have a TD is
it totally did whichever sections and things like that.
But the,
the,
I mean,
the way that these are done,
as you would have these huge lectures,
you don't want it.
Why I taught him that I shouldn't,
I get back to the goal,
but in seminary,
but when I taught at the Leon Do,
uh,
I was supposed to,
I didn't pick my courses here.
I'm lucky enough for you all to be able to pick my courses.
They said,
well,
you can do history of urban France cause I've written books on urban France and
then you can do,
um,
uh,
the 1920s and thirties.
And I thought,
aw man,
I don't do that.
And then you can do,
because we live part time in North America,
you can do a history of North America.
And No,
I don't think about that.
And so I'm calling my friends like David Davis and I'm calling my editors Upi in
Norton saying,
please send me all your books on American history.
And,
you know,
and so I'm sitting,
I'm the night before,
you know,
I'm,
I did ridiculous lectures on Quebec.
I don't think about that.
I must have repeated three times by Louis,
the 14th setting boatload of prostitutes because that's about all that I could
remember when I get up there in front of 250 people,
uh,
you know,
speaking about history of North America,
I don't know a damn thing about it.
I might know a little bit about it,
but not to teach it effectively.
But that's just that.
And then also because of the politics,
my,
the person that the dean,
I was at war with my friends there,
so they gave me the worst conceivable schedule where I had to go all the way up
on Friday for an afternoon class.
And my other classes are on Monday and Wednesday and all of this.
But,
but you're,
you're teaching these people and there were three courses on the 1920s and
thirties,
three lecture courses.
And we would get together and say,
what are you going to do?
And we were smart enough to say,
well,
I'll tell you what,
you do the economy stuff and I'll do the,
you know,
political stuff and I will kind of help each other out.
And uh,
you put down a reading list of books that you might hope that they would read
and maybe 10 m eight books maybe or something like that.
A reasonable amount.
And,
but there,
there are bookstores,
but there are no,
it's not your thing as course readings.
And what they used to do it at the Sorbonne is they would,
the professors would print out their lectures and you could buy at one of these
bookstores,
their lecture.
So he said,
well,
hell would,
I'm not going to go to the lecture if they're going to do that,
but,
but what we took it more seriously.
And so we put out these books and now it's to,
as trans students don't have any money,
they have no money.
I mean,
no money.
Uh,
most of them,
unless we had a fancy grounds,
they call it their,
their checkbooks had like Kleenex boxes,
ah,
that,
that they have no money.
They can't afford to buy the books.
No.
W in our three classes on the 1920s and thirties,
there were um,
400 students and you know how many copies of the books there were available?
One
in the library and there was another one in the municipal library in Lee Hall.
So how are you going to read the box?
You're not going to read the books.
How are you going to do on the tests?
Not very well.
I be,
cause you hadn't read the box and the whole course can't be built on the lecture
and then the,
you know,
and then it's,
but yeah,
it's good.
But I mean it's bad because you have,
they don't do it very good.
So I had students who were comparable to you,
nice people,
but then some of them were just totally clueless and they used to do things
like,
uh,
they were there.
One would bring,
a couple of them would bring these little stars that you have used to put on in,
haven't Catholic first grade,
we'll stars.
You'd put on the big points you want to have and they bring these little stars
and they thought there was still in high school and,
and,
and they'd say,
can I borrow the glue of my neighbor or can I buy that but borrow the eraser of
my neighbor.
And then everything in France has to be three.
So you'd have one,
you give them a question and say one,
two,
three.
And some of them would have three points and never made any sense at all.
But there were always three points,
but in some are just brilliant and some were terrible.
The thing was so sad about this whole system,
and this is really got me,
is that I had to do the travel of DOJ also have one of the courses.
And so somebody wouldn't be there and you'd say,
well,
Modena that met them,
you couldn't to trois them.
And uh,
so I finally end up doing it.
I mean hell with that.
And,
and,
uh,
you'd say whatever happened to my demos,
they'll eat,
where's met them?
Eat mademoiselle x Schipol was,
she's not here anymore.
No,
I guess not.
And you never know.
There'd be a nurse available for,
for,
uh,
you know,
for,
for 20 minutes a week.
And so if somebody was having serious problems,
you would never know.
No one ever followed it up and they just would disappear into the night.
And there was no structure.
I mean,
here,
if you get the sniffles,
we know about it.
Uh,
and you're taking very care of.
But I mean,
even it places that aren't fancy like this,
that's the way it is.
And so the system has never been reformed.
I mean,
even for simple tasks that,
oh,
here I go away,
this,
I'm getting it.
Ah,
what happened?
My lecture hell with it.
But,
uh,
you know,
waiting in line to Xerox something,
when you've ever waited line be behind that,
you know,
10 geographers all uh,
all xeroxing,
the 14 biggest volcanoes and the tweeter dome.
I mean,
it's just,
it's just mind boggling.
And then you're looking at your bell and then use to struggle through the
cigarette smoke.
You know,
hopefully you will see you,
you will see your amphitheater be,
will be,
you know,
somewhere through there and you sort of stagger along through the smoke and then
you,
you know,
and then people talk to,
the other thing is people talk and they used to drive him nuts and they all,
I mean the job too.
I mean,
they're all,
you know,
these guys are always hitting on these women and,
and,
and in your class and stuff is going on.
I once got so mad,
you know,
I gotta to of go to control myself.
I doubled it.
This an amphitheater be,
is this called?
So poetically,
I,
I wa was talking about some damn thing about Nouvelle Foss.
I mean,
I didn't know what I was talking about.
Z o z o and I,
you know,
I'm going on anyway,
it doesn't stop me.
And I walked up the,
uh,
I walk up the stairs and these people are talking a,
they're just talking.
And I stood right in front of him and then they said,
oh,
excuse me.
And then I left and went back down and they start talking again.
Or sometimes you have to be talking to is to ask you if you want to talk.
And they say,
oh no,
no,
excuse me.
And then,
then they go back to their email or they go back to their,
you know,
hitting on their neighbor or whatever.
I mean,
it just,
it was mind blowing,
but the very good students,
but,
but the way that you teach and a Diane has been,
knows a lot about the system to him.
You should ask her,
but,
but she was in Britain,
you know,
very,
uh,
you know,
very good schools and all that there.
But,
but,
uh,
I,
it,
it just is,
it's an incredible thing,
but it's,
so,
it didn't really change very much from after the gall.
So what happened all Charles de Gaulle,
uh,
back to 1968.
What happens to him?
Well,
he takes a mysterious,
his trip,
he first,
he goes to Columbia music,
Lee's probably to finish those fully tall,
those,
uh,
cereal's on TV,
that he was watching.
And then he disappears and he goes to a button button in Germany.
Why did he go to button button in Germany when nobody really knows?
Probably the best explanation as he wanted to make sure that he had the support
of the French army.
Why is the French Army in Boston,
Boston?
Well,
the French armies and bottom bottom because that's part of French territory,
uh,
in the,
the opera opera gear and they're still occupying.
And so he announces that they're going to have a,
a,
that they're going to have a,
uh,
participation and this necessity of a participation in overcoming this crisis.
That's the word he uses participation.
He comes back.
And so in the meantime,
there's this huge march down the Sean sleazy to support him.
Uh,
the upper classes,
uh,
are clear that they will support the Gaullist a response no matter what it is.
That if,
as the army just shooting down students,
but they were,
aren't going to ever do.
But you know,
the brutality of the repression,
they will support that.
Uh,
they're quite happy to see people like Colin Bendy and the others who,
uh,
committed professional suicide go.
Uh,
and,
um,
uh,
basically,
you know,
basically things a calm down.
But the point is that the reforms were never a,
were never really a meaningful reforms.
I think it's safe to say really don't come to the French a university system.
Uh,
now the French university system,
uh,
is more open to people who are not just,
you know,
following their parents along in the university structure.
There are more workers,
uh,
sons and daughters and daughters above all now,
daughters of,
of uh,
and sons of,
a very ordinary people.
We know a good number of,
of of people your age or a little older who are university now,
uh,
who are the first people in their,
in the whole history of their families to go to,
uh,
to a university in and happily still at Yale and other places.
One can of thanks to,
to various changes at Yale and these other places,
we can find that.
Now this has changed.
But the problem is that,
uh,
as long as the,
as long as the economy is not able to absorb all these young people when they
get done,
uh,
there is no sense that,
that they're going to be able to go anywhere anyway,
particularly if they want to stay in the region where we live in which there's
not a lot of economic activity.
Thus,
we have one friend who got her master's had gone over and the only job that she
could find,
uh,
for the next two years was working at a Mcdonald's,
in nobler near Canola.
And now she's working for her parents.
Uh,
so I mean,
university the two to make universities more open to all kinds of people.
There's not necessarily solve the problem of what's going to happen to them in
the,
in the long run.
Now,
one of the things that has done that as of course,
it's the box itself and you know,
uh,
that,
that in France you take the baccalaureate exam,
I,
you take the,
what they call the block,
uh,
at about blog after the equivalent of your junior year in high school,
which includes the,
the French Bach,
and then you take the real bock at the end.
Now back,
I can't tell you what the number,
the percentage of the people who pass the BOC in 1968 is,
I don't know that it's probably,
was it probably about half,
um,
eh,
or maybe even less.
Of course it's steamed upwards over the last,
uh,
the last 15 years and it's now approaches 80%.
I mean,
that is still big pressure because you're,
you know,
one exam and it's,
you bet your life because then you can't go to the university if you don't pass
the BOC.
And there's big,
big pressure.
And if you get pretty close by a couple points,
then you know,
you can do it again.
You know that there's a possibility of doing it again within the next couple of
weeks if you're very,
very close.
We had a friend whose mother died and she was obviously very upset and you know,
she just barely made missed it.
And so they let her do it again.
So this puts a lot of pressure.
But also,
as I've said before,
that they'll,
you guys have streaming,
there are lots of people,
kids who are taken out of the University of the line toward university and
toward passing the buck,
you know,
quite early on because her teachers will invoke the parents and say,
your daughter and son,
you know,
has no business being in a school just like that.
I mean,
cruelty of it all.
And then,
you know,
they go off into a different,
different line.
And there are no,
sir,
I've said this before,
but there are no second chances in this system,
which can be a very,
very cruel system.
And not everybody pays,
pack passes the buck.
My,
my,
um,
my son,
uh,
has,
has a,
a buddy who managed to get a one on the Bach,
which is very difficult,
uh,
because it's graded from zero to 20.
Uh,
and he managed to get a zero,
uh,
comma,
25 and one thing,
uh,
earlier on.
And as well of a,
which is an earlier exam.
And so the University of life isn't cut out for everybody.
But,
uh,
I,
I couldn't,
in all honesty,
as much as I loved teaching in France.
And I do.
And it's not just because of the,
you know,
uh,
I mean,
I love the [inaudible] in French universities.
I,
I really do.
And I feel useful.
Uh,
and,
and it just,
it's,
it's a lot of fun,
but it's not,
and we've had chances to,
you know,
be there forever,
uh,
you know,
teaching there,
but it's just the conditions,
you know,
they're tough.
They're challenging conditions and,
and basically,
uh,
it wasn't enough for the gall to say,
we want more participation and to announce an election,
a referendum on,
on regional decentralization.
And that's how we walked off the stage.
And,
uh,
in 1969,
he just goes back to stomps off to Columbia.
They do is at least cause it's a referendum on his,
his leadership.
And that participation isn't enough.
That his,
this big gap between,
uh,
talking a good game about grand urine and all of that and not following through
with any kind of meaningful reforms helped generate this crisis.
And,
you know,
one cannot,
I mean it's,
it's pointless.
It's silly.
Look back and say this was,
uh,
the revolution revolution.
Monquet this was the mist revolution that like in 1936,
if Leon Blum and said,
workers of the world take over your factories,
all of them,
uh,
peasants occupy the fields that you work,
you know,
and it also,
maybe this wasn't going to happen and who knows,
if nothing probably good would've come out that are that anyway.
But a 1968,
uh,
was not a revolution that was going to be a meaningful revolution in the end.
I mean,
that generation was right.
I would like to say,
you know,
in opposing US policies,
uh,
in trying to create or insist on a more human world humane world,
in industrial relations,
uh,
and in the university,
I mean,
but be professors and administrators learn something after all of that,
but in a very centralized,
a state where more and more people have because they pass the block,
have back of access to universities that,
that,
that isn't necessarily going to solve the problem,
which,
which fundamentally comes down to,
uh,
the fact that there are not enough,
that there's a real crisis of,
of young people for young people now,
uh,
in France about,
but no light at the end of the tunnel is now argue on Wednesday.
That's part of,
of what's going on in the French suburbs as well.
So if you go to Paris and you walked up the boulevard,
San Michelle,
which is my least favorite boulevard in Paris because it's been destroyed by bad
zoning and has Mcdonald's all over the place,
uh,
and just,
the tourist hoards,
uh,
that if you go up there,
I,
you know,
think about these battles pitched battles were fought in 1968 and that merry
month of May and,
and,
uh,
and of barricades and part of,
you know,
revolution as part of French culture,
the memory of revolution.
But this revolution really,
uh,
you know,
days are running down to the prefecture and declaring a new regime are pretty
much over.
And,
uh,
this revolution,
a well intentioned,
a full of,
of,
uh,
of color,
full of integrity,
full of,
of character,
full of width.
It was a,
it was a witty revolution,
full of irony and appreciation of the human condition in the end,
uh,
for better,
for worse.
And I think probably for worse,
it didn't get very far.
And to an extent,
uh,
when can,
can look longingly back as,
as you can probably tell,
I still do see on Wednesday.